hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a trip to Yugoslavia this
is supposedly a horror game made in like
the VHS era and it's supposed to feature
like live-action stuff now I don't know
if that means movies or if that just
means pictures but it's about going to a
place you shouldn't go warning this is a
choice based game in which your
decisions will change the outcome of
others the game saves automatically
after you make a decision okay
this game isn't based on any real
conflict in Yugoslavia alrighty then I
have no idea if that's gonna go but it
was highly rated and it seemed really
interesting like taking these things
from a different perspective there's
always like the the power drill Massacre
that was really cool in this like old
style of horror stuff so speaking of
which I always meant to finish our drill
max occur but I wasn't sure oh it does
oh why am i is that me
oh wow my head okay
oh that's just a preview of everything
to come I thought that was all okay I'm
an idiot okay here we go
I thought that was happening now so what
are we doing then oh it's beautiful oh
it's gorgeous oh cool
is this Yugoslavia hello how are you
you have a good time probably not about
to but maybe now it's pretty nice with
the scenery and everything Oh Oh who the
hell is that
why is he in the middle of the road also
why are you in the middle of the road
I noticed you had a camera oh okay
hi my friend how are you doing am i dead
oh no I'm just in trouble Wow what's
okay alright step on my hand and then
step on my face that's really nice of
you guys what a warm welcome to
Yugoslavia okay alright so this is where
the choices come into play now I've
never played this before and I have no
idea all I'm gonna do is I'm gonna apply
my wise logic he's asleep I should take
his gun murder him then run away
although making any noise would probably
very bad idea okay QuickTime events
anything what do I do
[Music]
okay all right yeah okay all right yeah
okay are you gonna try to seduce him oh
he has a knife okay
ah yeah that was smart oh wait was I
supposed to do something oh oh
is he gonna die was I supposed to do
whoa oh
I spit in his face I think what it's not
gonna be that easy pay attention you
might survive what was I supposed to do
I didn't see any quick time advance what
happened where do you want the tape
using left shift and try again oh maybe
that was important because that was the
tutorial and that was telling me what
happens if I don't do it cuz otherwise I
might be an idiot left shift rewinds -
hopefully oh ah right shift okay oh
that's cool that's cool they really
nailed the effects of VHS
fast-forwarding okay here we go now well
what up okay I upped it i up real good I
got the ups I got all the ups also why
did they kill me just because I was
trying to escape why didn't they kill me
before then or am i a valuable prisoner
am I not who's is something I'm paying
attention I'm focusing all of my power
is invested in this moment
almost there oh I'm free then okay never
mind
uh-huh oh don't act like it was hard to
breathe in that thing
you got a perfectly good nose right well
he looks a little young to be a soldier
but I'm gonna give him the benefit of
the doubt oh yeah that's a nice gun
whoo oh I'm not a fan of this decision
but getting rid of the guard means one
less problem I should escape while I can
both of the guards will come after me
well I mean obviously I mean duh you got
it oh he's just sleeping
oh he's probably not even the one that
oh that's so whew that's grim man oh
that's really grim ah oh really oh
really oh you're not gonna do it oh
you're gonna wimp out oh you just wasted
time oh you're gonna wimp out like a
little baby
oh what a baby ah man that's not a
choice you just made a choice for me
come on man you got to be better than
wait what that's some intense thumping
music but I didn't even know okay so the
symbols mean certain things but I've
done goofed because I didn't know that I
was supposed to go to the right well oh
he's pissin I hooked an achievement
running away like a little [ __ ] baby as
fast as I can and making as much noise
as I can
oh now I'm just depressed I think my
foot hurts from stepping on that stick
all right man you gotta you gotta do me
proud here you're making me look bad all
right come on come on come on come on
I might go back and fix everything but
for right now come on come on we gonna
do hmm I'm just gonna stand there
awkwardly okay I could take him out
before he notices but he could use his
rifle against me maybe I should take his
rifle away first
but if he notices yeah I'm thinking
getting shot in the face by a rifle
isn't a good show
I'm gonna go with the bashing him with
the but bash him but bash him pretty
much the preview of the hey hey look
over here as I smack you in the face
okay
okay let me loot his wallet here because
that's probably what I came here for oh
boy
double gunning yeah yeah he's dead
alright okay moving along well that guy
was ugly and that was a long piss all
right I guess I was a good choice my
camera should be around here somewhere
photos of surrounding areas should be on
it and they might come in handy so
you're a journalist if I make it out
alive I'll show the world what happened
here I got kidnapped I don't know why Oh
am i oh and her chamber enter chamber I
don't like the I don't like the sound of
chamber okay this one's got an eyeball
or a boob and it's surrounded by Mickey
mooses this one's got a cat then the guy
looking out real scary like so I'm
thinking there's a guard behind that one
I'm gonna go with the boob in the rat oh
there was nothing in there Waga in Wazza
okay I window hello a window covered in
dust he said a bluebird is that nye I
can never tell okay so nothing here what
about this other one was that camera
okay got it
am i good okay well it doesn't sound
great ow ow am i dying
okay progress save I think I don't know
what else we're doing here
oh now I'm sad wait where'd my rifle go
I have a hundred and eleven bullets in
one magazine I don't like where this is
going what huh
why safety toggle oh that that's
probably important yeah we need that
okay
so safety has been to gould flip handgun
okay oh this is so weird actual
maintenance on the handgun okay check
magazine okay I'll do that
what happened to your finger what did
that happen how many runes
how many Blitz how many killi killi
shooty shooty bang bangers am I am I
good tat TAS the gun oh that's a good
idea
sounds like it's gonna make a lot of
noise and then probably waste the ball
I'm not gonna do that even though it's
the only choice presented in front of me
okay why why not why not oh oh that was
that was a good one that was good one
here let's try that again with a little
more umph
Oh smart don't shoot your balls off
yeah no one will notice that no I don't
notice that you're the stealthiest
reporter to ever go to Yugoslavia okay
grassland tents in the distance mansion
what is over the mansion who's that a
helicopter okay so we got it's some kind
of mansion the helicopter above it tends
in the distance it's a camp can't see
very well from here so I'm guessing
there's probably a lot of military
people over there so I can go in the
grassland er I've known the forest
something tells me the forest is
probably gonna be more secluded and
harder to find me in okay of course
there's no need to go forward I think
I'm safe for now
Oh what you think you're safe why why do
you think you're safe you got kidnapped
see the season is taking its toll
okay Oh bye knocks oh good I found by
knocks okay so I should be able to see
something now huh if I squeeze miles
real hard it's empty as well what's
going on are they moving out I guess how
about the mansion oh it's empty
how so how is it empty I see a dude
right there and a motorcycle and a whole
bunch of stuff oh you get Adele's empty
okay then so forest the forest seems a
bit dense around this area
good great camouflage oh hello where'd
you come from you weren't there before
okay then they're after me Paul [ __ ]
they spotted me with their by knocks oh
God okay so forest forest okay in the
forest okay good I made the right choice
here ivz hmm hi oh hell yeah oh hell
yeah you can't catch me
not even with your bullets oh jeez
laughs yeah but boom I got you good
well they're both still there okay
they're both alive and not dead okay
yeah oh my god I gotcha oh oh no oh oh
oh that winded me a little bit ooh ooh
I guess he's okay though apparently
maybe I've just got a BB gun they're
just really scared of it
okay oh [ __ ] dude
Oh down
yeah that's down why are they just
standing there huh bang oh no oh I need
to lie down for a moment I do need to
catch my breath
okay well I got him to Bassets the guns
on me
that would have been a shame oh here we
are
wherever this what happened to you did
you get shot they didn't use their guns
watch I watched
well hope you're okay both limping and
holding your arm
how did did did they just stream a line
a bullets down your right side
completely but it was all flesh wounds
all across the surface oh and now you're
passing out what what an adventure he's
all tuckered out it was too late to run
away oh the entire town was overrun by
enemy soldiers I decided to stay low
behind the enemy lines hoping that I
could get back home but that's when I
knew I was the war has begun war were
declared 505 months later
oh we're fast-forwarding okay I've got a
ghillie suit just made completely out of
bushes you'll never see me I got my bail
good I'll get you I'm not gonna hesitate
this time you're in fine I'm coming for
ya yeah you'll never hear me coming
while I'm yelling how about a murder
yeah where's the murder the garden might
not be illness maybe I should just knock
him out no I'm gonna murder him where he
stands that time I'm not gonna miss was
the back of my knife you know i'm rony
Kenshin but I never kill oh he's dead am
I gonna pull out like I look like a
picture of his family or something okay
okay all right well time to decorate my
home some more than I've been living in
for five months they'll never notice
that one of their soldiers have been
gone dead but if I'd have just knocked
an out then he might have come after me
so I think it's probably for the best
well now that I got a rifle back because
somehow I lost it whoa oh there's
something over the horizon I'm gonna get
it oh I'm readying my fightin fists
oh it's those chambers I remember oh
well that's no good
that's pretty grandma okey-dokey then
is that a sniper rifle in the back there
so one of them might be a sniper
all right well what am i doing was like
just so appalled by it let's see a melee
weapon could be useful but I could risk
getting spotted in I should leave while
I still have the chance but other than
this rifle I don't have any other weapon
well you know having a rifle seems like
a pretty good idea for a weapon I'm not
a hundred percent sure about things but
you know as far as a Kalashnikov goes
not the worst thing in the world so I'm
gonna be stupid and go for the melee
weapon just gotta watch this terrain Oh
sprained my ankle a little bit over
there hello don't worry about me though
I've taken like dozens of bullets just
to my right side but this is the first
time my left side got hurt so I think
I'll be okay Lita the sneakiest
sneakiest journalist that ever did live
I haven't managed to get a gun except
for this one moment five months later I
want to get it I'm gonna flank left I'm
gonna dodge to the right I'm gonna do a
somersault and then spin my ribbon baton
and then hopefully you know maybe sleep
with one of the judges and then get a
high score but for now I'm gonna get
this okay yeah bypass that machine gun
on the ground there
I passed the sniper rifle go for the
shovel this is totally worth the shovel
why would they why why would they
they're talking we're gonna have a
conversation away from these dead bodies
this smells really getting to me alright
I should run while they're distracted I
have a low chance of getting shot while
I'm running sneaking away is risky but
if they don't around I should be able to
get away safe okay so it's either
guaranteed they look or you know maybe
they don't look they're probably gonna
look yeah they don't have their guns
with them
Rodney run run run like those run like
the little baby you are
run a bang it didn't work
Oh God my spine well that sucks okay
let's rewind it here
we know forward it there what Oh get
away from their sticky keys I don't need
you alright sneak away yeah yeah yeah
maroon sneak like the wind no no no no
no no no sneaking no no no no no no no
no nah really interesting conversation
Nana Nana Nana no need to turn around
and look the dead bodies you buried nuh
nuh nuh nuh okay anyway probably look
it's the other side of the chamber
alright
they've got a sniper and they got a
really really well-trained soldier this
time because he actually knows how to
lift his gun up in the air don't mess
with that guy alright so staying around
and taking them by surprise might be
slow but maybe it's less of a risk
attacking them head-on is dangerous but
this is what they do I deserve to go out
Rambo style the answer is hell yeah I do
oh wow that's some serious effects over
there down yeah oh man is this actually
gonna work up boom okay so so the the
QuickTime event is the direction that
the body is facing
oh these oh these guys are gonna get ah
huh
he was just gonna take a nap you know
and I'm like one shot one kill
Rambo here is crazy
yeah check the windows make sure they're
all dead
are they all dead they look all dead oh
one more BAM
oh oh I got him yay
murdered everybody hooray I'm oh I I
literally am I'm behind enemy lines and
I'm picking off their entire army one by
one ah don't know how yeah the guy
didn't want to get it on his friends so
he's like should I shove it in his face
yeah all right on his owner's code there
be a little nice I bet he did I bet
there's outtakes of where he's like
shoveling right on its friend's face
there cuz obviously this was made by
just like a group of friends I wanted to
do a project and I really appreciate
that I hope any of my stupid jokes
hasn't come across as me making fun of
this I think this is really cool I
really am enjoying myself here because
it reminds me of what I used to do you
know I didn't have video camera
equipment like this but you know just
going out in the woods and [ __ ]
around it's just like really cool and
and they didn't just make a movie out of
it which is a lot of what a lot of
people do they made a game out of it did
I have a nap
what happened did five months go by I
missed it I was rambling I'm Rambo
rambling I'm Rambo bowling that's what I
mean by stupid joke it's a bad one that
doesn't make anybody laugh you okay
there buddy why did it go all blue Oh
sneak mode engaged
I love it like standing up straight
sneak Oh stand fully up no notice me
even now Ellie like all the sneak is is
he's gonna slate hunch in his back look
lowering my profile no one else see me
oh [ __ ] so so what's so spooky about
this building so I'm gonna happen why'd
you only bring a knife
oh hey is he sleeping - why is everybody
asleep and also stupid oh no that guy
might be dead that guy might be
legitimately dead oh man I'm making a
lot of noise boy this this guy better be
dead because if he's not then he has no
excuse and he's about to be dead
Oh Oh he is asleep Oh lolling his head
from side to side I didn't have a single
quick damn event there and that's what I
was expecting it okay oh okay all right
then BAM he's like this guy's been
through it before this soldier this
soldier knows what's up he knows the
deal is like oh caught sleeping again oh
you want my hat would you like my hat
sir
oh geez oh geez
yeah even now he's like okay let me get
a more comfortable position so that I
can take a nice nap thank you sir
everyone else hasn't killed me thus far
see I should just go searching for
ammunition two bandages first in case I
need to defend myself searching for food
and water would make me stay alive
longer on my own yeah it seems like more
important so let's do that one cuz I got
like 15 guns there's got to be some
bullets in there I took out an outpost
they usually stock those [ __ ] okay so
maybe maybe I'm gonna find something
maybe maybe but not 100% okay maybe I
should risk it and go for it I can't
lose too much time or I'll get caught
maybe I should just look through the
windows just to be sure there's no one
there yeah I'm gonna do the Lyne though
the window looking you know oh I got an
achievement I don't know what I did but
I got one cool dude there's food and
water in there there's some lovely food
in water but why would it just be
staying in the middle there yeah let me
stab this brick real quick okey-dokey
then maybe I should have just gone for
it
cuz it doesn't seem to be anybody in
there also I love the graffiti
wait there's a cameraman in here oh [ __ ]
oh never mind then he's my friend he's
my only friend okay
man I really could have just jumped in
there uh-huh
well that took a lot of time it I still
have some spare time to look for the
munition yeah so what was the point of
that what was that okay then since the
shovel bought me some time I can use it
to find some bandages oh oh oh I guess I
don't know how the shovel bought me any
time Oh am I gonna hit him with this
shovel please tell me I'm gonna hit him
with this shovel I really want to hit
him with the shovel he doesn't seem to
be going off his patrol pathway maybe I
should just wait until he moves I don't
have much time for waiting I guess I
could go for a risk and find a different
way in yeah sure let's do that because
who knows me I mean everybody goes off
to have conversations and take pisses
around here so it couldn't be too bad
Oh who are you aren't you the soldier
that they just buried the other day or
other month or I can't tell time right
now I don't know about you but a problem
I probably noticed this oh oh no oh no
dead dead hundreds n dead oh well this
is awkward man they must really care
about this soldier
don't try anything stupid how are you
gonna grab it oh okay yeah okay all
right yeah that yeah okay
yeah okay yeah okay well then it went
better than expected
I think about right about now they'd
probably you know grab their guns up and
start shooting at me right about then
that would happen okay I'm being overly
critical but I mean I just I can't I
can't let that live that's that's kind
of just like right in front of my face
here so I got ammunition and I got food
and water oh and now they're coming for
me and I got a helmet somewhere
somewhere I've got a helmet it's got all
it's got an opener I saw one Oh was that
a grenade ah they spent their entire
pyrotechnics budget right then in there
what am i dead
am i okay why is that guy guys literally
ten meters oh that was not a smart
choice on that guy's part also I'm not
having any more quick time events hey oh
it's me helmet guy remember we're
friends oh this seems like a trap what
seems like a trap don't shoot who are
you all over
wait the war the war is over he is part
of this war and in war there will be
bloodshed but maybe he deserves a chance
I'm gonna go with that
I like helmet guy tell my guys my face
we're friends now bro let's do it like
Arnold Schwarzenegger and that other guy
yeah okay
ow what well how did he betray me did he
just punch me give me a friendly punch
is this is this your is this my home now
because it's my home I have no idea oh
man I love this like I said I don't want
any of my stupid jokes to get in the way
of this or you think that I don't like
this because no I love this because I
love the essence of it I love what it is
it's it's a group of friends trying to
make something and you know they made it
like they made it fully they committed
to it you know it's not great but it's a
unique take on it and it's done in a
weird way oh and I got bandages
let me just drape it over like a Miss
Universe sash yeah cuz I won I ended the
war that guy when he said it was over
the war is all over and everything will
be a-okay so this will do it it's
left4dead style you're just kind of like
swirl it around your body and a few
locations and your HP goes up to maximum
or a little bit below maximum oh oh this
injury is too Grievous for a sash like
like this like the serious of the
situation and the silliness of his two
straps of bandage yeah yes I love that I
love that I'm critical of a few aspects
of it but it's all in good fun I really
love that even though towards the end it
was like there was less QuickTime events
but maybe they just spent it all on that
one rampage in but still ah that was
cool like legitimately I'm not even
saying that as like like as good effort
no legitimately that was cool it was
something I've never done before or I've
never seen before
and they tried something new and they
made it they honestly went out and they
made it and I don't know how hard it was
to make I mean obviously you gotta have
like storyboards for all the branching
paths and what you want but if it the
best with what they had and obviously
these guys are young and they're trying
something and it was still pretty cool
like legitimately I I don't want to
overstate I'm not criticizing like the
deeper aspects of the tow we the
gameplay was all rubber necks like
obviously the game was not there but for
what it was at it's very deep court was
cool and I like that so either way thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought of this or let
me know what you thought of a trip to
Yugoslavia down in the comments below
I'd love to visit Yugoslavia it sounds
like a great place maybe I will someday
so thank you again and as always I will
see you in the next video bye wait a
minute wait bring it back bring the tape
back whoa wait a minute whoa I got the
all lies ending you thought and
attempted to kill a sleeping guard you
decide to arm yourself before attacking
no data what did I miss there and this
is another thing so don't bring more
about it is like it has choices you just
chose to take the life of a patrolling
guard why does this is a total enemies
killed zero you took a risk and obtained
a shovel you showed your enemies war
yeah I'm pretty sure I killed a lot food
and water were chosen over ammo and
bandages surrendered soldier was spared
oh that's the end of it that's weird
oh that's cool though so I wonder how
many different endings there were and
why did to say all lies I think some of
the tracking may have been a little bit
off there but you know still not too bad
I guess we're done here so see you
around
[Music]